[Music]
austin
is not on that line austin is on that
line in cincinnati hi austin how are you
hey dave chris how are you guys great
man how can we help
good um so i've been listening to you
for about a year now
and uh i've paid off about 20 000 so far
um i'm actually currently working on my
car paying that off
i ran into my first issue um i took it
to the dealership and they were able to
they said they were able to temporarily
fix the issue
i guess this is something to do with the
computer um
my question is should i sell this car
and take what equities in it now or do i
ride it out and take the chance of the
computer going out
was the dealership trying to sell you a
new car
uh i don't think so it's it's only worth
about five thousand so
they weren't suggesting you upgrade with
them
no they didn't say that now okay okay
austin have you had an issue
with this car before no um no it's been
good so far
and you've had it how long it just hit a
hundred thousand miles
okay but i forgot to mention this i
drive about 500 miles for work
every week so that's my concern is that
the miles are going to start really
getting up there and more issues are
going to come up yeah well i mean what
kind of car is this
it's a chrysler 2015 chrysler 200. okay
well here's the thing what i would do is
do a little bit of research i don't know
much about that particular car and see
if the computer programs
if problems with the computer are
ongoing and if you've got something
that's going to blink out on you
and you want to sell it and buy car of
equal or lesser value
in order to keep getting the job done
sure
if the the of course the other thing you
could do is get a mechanic that's not
at a dealership to look at it because uh
sometimes a dealership um not all of
them but some of them have been known to
say
oh this thing's a bum car you need to
walk right out here son and i'll show
you another one i mean yeah they'll try
to upgrade you that's why i was asking
about that
doesn't sound like that's what happened
here put all your troubles behind you
just gonna know here's the reality too i
i'm with you
i would sell this thing get something
reliable that you can put these miles on
less or more not more money right and
then budget
and set aside that dollar amount uh that
was one of the things that was a game
changer for me dave when i got plugged
in
on the envelope system was starting to
make a car payment to myself
saving up to be able to pay cash for a
car you sell the one you got take your
cash and you go get something new to you
and what's weird is when you start
paying a car payment to yourself and
you're looking at i'm saving up to buy
something you met you pay
you put more in the account yeah you do
you don't end up going 323.36
you go i think i put 500 a month in
there you know and you start chunking a
little more in there because you know
500 a month for 10 months that's 5000
bucks i can move up pretty much
yeah with that that's a nice chunk up
but yeah your independent mechanics out
there
there's tons of really really good ones
and
just have somebody else look at it give
you a second opinion the most expensive
place to work on a car is at the
dealership
from a repair standpoint they make more
money
per square foot if you read national
auto dealers associations literature
the per square foot at the dealership in
other words their rent
the most money they make per square foot
is the finance office
when they sell you something on paper
and they sell that paper to the bank
they make more on that than they do the
stinking car
and the second area they make the most
money on is in the shop
service department service farm
yeah and then all those acres and acres
and acres of cars out there
they don't make that much money on they
sell them in order to get you on
payments and get you in the shop
that's where the money comes from get
the hooks into you follow
the money i'm not mad at car dealers a
lot of my buddies are car dealers and
i'm not afraid of you to buy a brand new
car once you got a net worth of a
million dollars that's all fine and
i drive really nice vehicles and i take
them to a dealership but that's a highly
unusual situation
so most of the time when i've been
driving cars
growing you know throughout my life and
i'm 60 years old
is i take them to a good independent
mechanic
and those guys will give you a good give
you a good rundown on what's going on so
get a second opinion
then decide do a little research then
decide if you want to sell it don't go
into debt to move up
and use this situation as
rationalization
yes to do that and especially let me
talk to especially single moms out there
i think they get preyed on the most
uh talking about you on a safe vehicle
for you and your children and this and
that and
i'm telling you don't fall for that you
know be aware that keep your hand on
your purse
uh find a good mechanic throughout your
church or in your community that can
look over your car
and shoot you straight about what's
wrong and the cost of repairs
don't ever hesitate to get a second
opinion what happens to all of us is
um when your car breaks down two things
activate
uh you get pissed off yep and there's a
sense of insecurity i'm stuck
i can't get where you know fear i can't
get where i need to go
so it's cold weather or i'm out in the
middle of no stinking ware
and i'm vulnerable it doesn't matter who
you are yeah
and you've got this hassle this
inconvenience
and those emotions will cause people to
do some of the dumbest things
financially
ever they'll be stuck out there on a 5
000
car and then go finance a 20 000 car
on impulse because they get so angry or
so afraid
over the hassle factor and the sense of
vulnerability of the car breaking down
fix the car all cars break
there are no cars that don't break some
of them break less
because they're newer better built i get
that
but all cars break there are reliable
i can't drive a used car honey after
you've been driving it six months what
do you call that
used that's what you call it this is the
dave ramsey show